happy birthday to you Michael Irvin how
are you sir
I am here again yes I'm doing well rich
listen yes I am 47 Oh plus seven okay I
know you I stopped taking the numbers as
Sunday sometimes some place we should be
able to say no more numbers I'll take a
celebrated day yes but I'm not adding on
any numbers I am 47 was my favorite
number my College dimmers I stopped
taking ages at 47 so forty seven plus
seven you can say that well I'm not
people it's in that vein I celebrated my
20th annual 30th birthday just this past
year right but I choose 30 just because
it's a number you choose 47 because
that's your number from the you though
right Irv correct 47 means young enough
to be I saw Jamie Foxx joking about he
said he was doing a show and he said one
of the girls came to him it's a how old
are you he's baby's 49 50 you have the
49 like you know like it's a disease
when you hit that age you already so I
just thought let me just stop at 47 it's
just an years laughing well happy late
happy belated birthday Irv let's get
into it
of course let's get into it why why is
Brady being attached in any way shape or
form even rumored to the Cowboys is
there anything possible on that front
well there was so much talk about it
early on and then I was out and not LA
but Miami for the Super Bowl and I even
talked with some people about it because
I thought there's no way that's
happening and then when I started
talking to people I thought wait a
minute alright yeah I thought it was no
way is happening because there's no
interest on either side then I learned
that there is some insurance interest
on one of the sides and I kind of woke
me up and said wow but but I don't think
there's a possibility of that happening
in order for any deal to happen both
sides gotta have to agree I just heard
you talking about
Brady bull being a bull and a china shop
reinforcing his way to San Francisco but
even that you know Brady is great he's
the greatest they ever do it and he
should have an opportunity and New
England is giving them that opportunity
to pick a place go pick a place if you
get another opportunity you will give it
to you you burnt that but the other
place also has to pick him and and right
now I just don't see it happening in
Dallas well I mean yeah that one when I
heard that Dallas I mean look at some
point they're gonna figure out Dax
contract at some point that has to that
has to be handled and even if somehow
someway it's not no franchise Tagum
right I mean and and figure figure out
how to take now between now and July and
and if need be go into the the season
with him on a cousin's contract right
Irv I mean that's the way it's gonna go
with Jack and not a bad number something
like that third driver 30 and I don't
know what exactly 30 32 through 28 so
all of that is good number all that is
good number just to be franchised and
then of course the next year be what 39
or something like that or so so we're
talking about incredible numbers but I
think what's best for the Cowboys and
and hopefully that says and sees what's
best for him is before them to work out
a long-term bill I team works around
that the great thing about the one thing
about Tom's you bring Tom Brady enriched
he's got to bring in everything that Tom
does you got to bring in his system and
I'm not saying that if you do happen to
bring in Tom that you that you should
exactly what you should do is bring in
his system and and and that would be
quite quite a thing III did a show here
and guys will ask me what do you think
Tom can make a difference I said let me
give it to you this way give Tom the
talent that doc had around him in New
England last year do you think they have
a chance at where the Super Bowl and
answer has to be absolutely yes
hmm so um you heard about Amari Cooper
right what he had to say locally Irv he
says you want yeah okay I think they
have that sound bike do we have that mic
del Tufo can you play Amari Cooper to
set up the conversation I love being a
Dallas Cowboy I love everything about it
I was thinking about that today I think
about it almost every day really oh you
know just primetime game doesn't play
but seems like more night games than
anybody and that always feels good to a
football player um you know everything
the facility I love it here first though
I said now um miss tiara being a Dallas
Cowboy I mean can't beat it so I want to
be a Dallas Cowboys for life well you
know what that means you were down as
cowboy for life Irv do you think he's
going to get that I hope so rich I've
been telling everybody and everybody's
talking about you know gotta get back -
yeah but why invest all that money if
you give them no one that's roll it - so
we have to make sure that you also get a
Mars son you remember what it was like
we were doing those shows a couple years
ago before Amari Cooper chained the
Dallas they looked horrific at the wide
receiver position which made that look
terrific you don't want to go back to
that you do not want to go back to that
if anything once you did this man the
kind of money that Doc's going to
command and demand and it's demanding
you got to give them help around it so
somehow someway I love hearing that
Amari Cooper loves being here and that's
and I come see also talk about his great
relationship with that Prescott and he
understands that sometimes when you get
traded
you don't always end up in a lucky spot
like that so so hopefully they'll be
able to get that deal done and when
Terry here's that interview back there
oh so you're willing to work with me on
this that's what hey that's what Jerry
hears when he hears I want to be a
cowboy for life set me also you're
willing to take a little bit less stay
here for life I guarantee you'll bring
that up I love that
and what's going on with des is there
any there there about a reunion Earth
III was with there the other night at
the basketball game man speaking on risk
watching Zion and Luke will go and I was
a card I was it was incredible man it's
just phenomenal watch those two guys
really was when I was with him at the
game and I talked about it and we talked
about it and I'm gonna tell you
something his face just like up it blows
my mind how much of a cowboy he is you
know I remember couple years ago when
when when Baltimore was all for him a
three year deal I don't know maybe 25 30
million dollars or whatever and he
basically just said no I don't want it I
don't but now he's ready to come back to
play for Dallas for poor for a lot lot
lot lot lot they put one more a lot on
lot left and that's it that's amazing
that tells you how much he loves the
Cowboys and really I think he only
really wants to play for the Cowboys but
I think that have been an interesting
pickup if they made that pickup because
I gotta tell you something it's hard to
be an alpha male an alpha male apple
says first apple says everything comes
through me and then all of a sudden to
come back to that same uniform that same
helmet in the same locker room and now
you don't make a bill you know now
you're the bottom not now have agency in
now you go from being first to the last
and it's a hard thing in the same
uniform in the same locker room you go
from being first to last
it'll be interesting to see how that
worked out well the question is Jerry I
mean Jerry Jerry said he thought about
it in the shower but what but but you
know hey man all I said go up and get
the ball you know he went off
I got the ball so I don't know what he's
in the shower thinking about hopefully
thinking about their still having the
ability to get up get the ball
it makes the play alright Michael Irvin
here on the Rich Eisen show so where do
you think Brady's thinking right now cuz
you know III do believe he is thinking
San Francisco like deep down I think he
wants to see if that's possible there's
no doubt every player will tell you okay
that ultimately he wants to play for the
team that he grew up loving that's the
ultimate dream to one day line up you
either want to play for the team you
grew up loving I'll play for the team
and that you know that that's right
there in your hometown sometimes you
know maybe sometimes there's another
team but like me I always wanted to play
for the doll I mean I love the Cowboys
my dad was a cowboy fan but I mean I
mean I wanted I wanted to go help Dan
Marino get that Super Bowl i watch mark
Clayton and Mark people so I know that
would be incredible for him and that
King is right there that team is right
there I said last year that Super Bowl I
thought San Fran would win it but I knew
it would come down to Jimmy Garoppolo
making plays in the end and and and they
were right there that he may hit that
pass to Emmanuel Sanders maybe they win
that football game and that was the
difference right there in that football
game so I there's no doubt in my mind
Tom Brady would love to go home
especially with that team that he has
right there did Jimmy ever call you you
know when you were perhaps towards the
end of your career and say how about
come play with me one more time in Miami
if you were physically able to do it you
ever get a call like that earth no we
never really had that conversation by
then I was already two engrafted with
the Dallas Cowboys to leave a place that
I want three Super Bowls right they're
going try to be you know what I mean and
try to build onto something at that
place I just didn't think that was that
was viable for me and you know I think
things are changed now but back in the
day rich it was it was it was more it
was more it was great to be able to stay
with one team
now everybody even in basketball and
football LeBron is ready to pop your uh
you gotta go and do your thing when your
contract is up and bounce around kind of
be a higher higher gun but but I still
like the idea I still hope Tom Brady
plays in New England
I still hope but you know but but but
who am i i i i wanted michael join me in
Chicago and that didn't work out so so
certainly this could have a possibility
tom brady ending up somewhere else all
right before I let you go it's a weird
question asked live on the air but I'm
asking anyway because it was something
we talked about for me an hour one your
uber rating do you know do you have your
uber rating do you know that what that
would be off the top of your head
Michael no and I overrated I'm like who
knows they're over well here's what you
do do you have your few out B of your
phone with your over app on your phone
right now right Irv I do okay open it up
go ahead and open it up and then look at
your top left when you open it up it
should say your name and then you should
be a number in the top left portion of
your app and you tell me what it is but
did we just get him back on the phone by
the way here's a guy who says I'm not an
old man you gotta call him back all
right dude I got it
what's your berating do you know it when
I click the top left button hold on the
fetus - it's your click on your over
button and then go top that you see the
three horizontal lines at the top left
so what's your rating yeah four five
four four five four RIT almost four
seven
[Applause]
listen how great that is for 747 I just
[Music]
coming everybody loves Michael Irma what
the hell I did nothing I did nothing to
earn this rating and I can't I'm in a
Riptide I can't get out of it no matter
how nice I am how do they give you the
rate and what are they rating at all
I got a rating our own tips are talking
to people how well questions we but
we've had over drivers calling in
throughout the entire show so far and
they have told me you know they they'll
just give people who vomit in their car
five stars you know and others will say
like if we want you to talk we want it I
mean that's it's it's like you know
different strokes for different folks
Irv but obviously I have to take
pictures I have to sign autographs I get
a five of five why do I ever have not
that I'm playing about a four seven
cause I see it's up to me but yeah I
should have a five because I'm giving
them value not just the money
yes exactly your value add your value
added ride harder that's the competitive
spirit that puts you in Canton right
there on this play I just want know that
beat you rich about that and what are
the world when I beat you in anything
when we start talking about Oh like
customer satisfaction kind of everywhere
when it comes to you in a comparative
analysis except Hoover hands me better
and I appreciate you happy birthday
happy birthday take care of